good morning Hank it's Monday I love
Brazil did you know the Brazilian
nerdfighters petitioned Brazilian
publishers to publish Looking for Alaska
in Portuguese and it totally worked
god I love Brazil hi today I want to
tell you a story about Brazil in the
United States that I first heard on the
amazing podcast planet money there's a
link to that below but I also have to do
some errands today so walk with me so
like this t-shirt and yes I'm wearing my
face on my torso is made from 100%
American cotton like almost all cotton
t-shirts in the world why because the
United States massively subsidizes its
cotton industry all right I got to get a
water filter from my fridge let's drive
the US spends more than three billion
dollars a year on its cotton subsidy
which has the effect of making the price
of American cotton artificially cheap
that's a bit of an oversimplification
but in my defense I am currently driving
on snow right so these cotton subsidies
don't just make American cotton cheap in
America they make American cotton cheap
everywhere which is why the u.s. is by
far the world's largest exporter of
cotton that's great for the American
cotton farmer but it kind of sucks for
all the non-american cotton farmers it
also sucks for those of us who were
Americans who aren't cotton farmers
because all we get for that 3.1 billion
dollars in taxes is like slightly
cheaper t-shirts must resist urge to eat
cheeseburgers
so under international trade agreements
some agricultural subsidies are legal
but you're not allowed to artificially
lower the price of something and in 2002
Brazil filed a case with the WTO saying
basically when it comes to cotton
Americans are a bunch of cheating
cheaters of cheater II and they're
illegal cotton subsidies have made it
completely impossible for Brazilian
farmers to compete even to sell cotton
in Brazil because American cotton is so
artificially cheap in 2004 the WTO sides
with Brazil says American cotton farming
subsidies are completely illegal
whereupon the United States says we're
rubber you're glue WTO rulings bounced
off us and stick to you wholly snood
adulthood is expensive
we completely refuse to comply just keep
appealing and appealing and finally in
2008 we lose our last appeal whereupon
we're like you know what nah we're not
going to comply which we can totally do
because it turns out there's no actual
penalty for failing to follow trade
agreements we got to go to the grocery
store so after the u.s. failed to abide
by the WTO s decision that US cotton
subsidies were illegal Brazil's the only
real recourse was retaliation but if
you're a small economy in a fight with a
huge economy your retaliation options
are a little limited like if Liberia
doesn't like American cotton subsidies
they can say you know what we're
attacks All American imports to Liberia
and in America we'll be like okay and
that's probably how this fight with
Brazil would have ended ten years ago
but what happened in the meantime is
that Brazil became a big economy nowhere
near the size of the US certainly but
big which is why when Brazil threatened
to tax American imports like
pharmaceuticals and cosmetics those
companies called their friends in the
American government and said you got to
do something about this cotton business
and they did come to an agreement in
April of 2010 the United States
announced that it would pay Brazilian
cotton farmers a hundred forty seven
million dollars a year in order to
continue subsidizing our own cotton
farmers illegally to the tune of three
billion dollars a year and that Hank is
how the United States came to subsidize
the Brazilian cotton industry if we were
going to be fair we should subsidize
every cotton industry in the developing
world but Brazil was the only country
that was smart enough to sue us and big
enough to scare us like I said earlier I
love Brazil but I don't want to send
their cotton farmers 147 million dollars
each year Hank I'll see you on Wednesday
by the way nerdfighters the American
taxpayer has already paid for a
significant portion of this t-shirt if
you'd like to pay for the rest of it you
can do so at dftba.com slash Pizza it's
in stock ships immediately and thanks to
bad economic policymaking it's only 18
dollars